[Music]
surprised we still get news out of
russia
oh this is this is the the news that we
need to report because if we don't
report this people will find out and
then people won't learn is this is this
going to be the downfall of the russian
empire i won't go that far but
definitely definitely the downfall of uh
anyways does putin have hemorrhoids now
or something that's news no no no we
have jk people on the field there yeah
that'll be so dope that's steve
steven's on the field like the most
unqualified person in the middle of the
war
we're gonna stick out so where's
brittany grimer that's what he says so a
body of a woman
uh-huh
was eaten by 20 pet cats holy [ __ ] after
she died at her residence she's so she
was like a cat if you're gonna die
around 20 cats that are starving whoever
you asked you asked for it she probably
loves those cats this could happen
anywhere else it needs to be russia the
opinion of jk well it's like if you're
gonna die in front of your hungry cats
stop looking so tasty i heard that if
you died like with the dog they won't
eat you but if you die with a cat they
will yeah oh really dogs won't eat you i
don't know what if they're really hungry
that's because cats are efficient and
they understand how the world works you
know what i mean you think a cat person
that's like i have to nowadays so in
this shocking incident right uh this
woman was allegedly eaten by her 20
maine [ __ ] cats
those are expensive really how much
what's the street price like i had a i
had a client that got theirs actually
shipped from maine and it was
he's all excited he was like oh i'm
going to get my amazon friend today and
she's like oh
anybody not familiar with a maine [ __ ]
cat they're so pretty they're very nice
they're very very very pretty dude they
would destroy my allergy yeah i feel
like there's only like five
versions of cats
there's the garfield looking one there's
that [ __ ] one there's that
have you seen the short leg cats yeah
they're so cute but i feel like they're
in constant pain would you wear cat fur
anthony
if it would if it looked dope as [ __ ]
like it was like a north face jacket and
the collar was like
the partial remains were found inside
the residence and it was surrounded by
hungry cats after initial investigation
they were still hungry after that
[ __ ] cat for a dude no one would dog
further what if it was kenji's aesthetic
yeah kind of like in front of a
fireplace they put a tiger there but
then you just do a cat oh yeah yeah but
at least with a tiger at least you have
that like coverage with a tiny cat it's
like this
it's this tiny little rug in the middle
no you do like
[Laughter]
that's like a small bear yeah it's a
little maintenance this is a little lamb
or sheep right a little maine [ __ ] right
there they're fluffy dude i'm vegan dude
i don't you're talking about all right
um so hold for a corporate center
is that really how it sounds when you
edit because you're making really
exciting sounds yeah
i just like making sounds too got it
he's trying to be like the police
academy the black guy yeah michael
winslow no carl winslow actually
people don't know it's the same guy the
only sound he makes go home
carl winslow did die hard first and then
he got that job from the inspiration of
that right yeah i think so he was about
to quit acting oh wait no and crocodile
dundee was a limo driver right who
became a cop in the sequel but he all
looked like the same uniform
i'm thinking about the limo driver in
die hard but that was the kid right yeah
yeah that guy was cool too man
so about this cat coat you're wearing um
yeah you're going go and show us your uh
your cat fur there it is nice so in joe
malia you wear cat for everyone okay
everyone gets a throw rug do they even
make
cat fur coats
like i'm not going to google that right
now that's what you're going to do open
your tour browser
i don't know if i'd still be allergic to
it well this was like this was like a
standard this was like when i was
watching 101 dalmatians as a kid and
thinking i'm like is cruella deville
really gonna kill a hundred mini dogs to
make one coat or one i knew she was yeah
but like why why wouldn't she just kill
big dogs and cause puppy for a softer
and she wants the dots on there yeah
you're right the fact that you knew that
that's very cute of you i was a fan of
hers oh cruella deville
i kind of liked her i actually really
enjoy her as an evil villain for all the
disney [ __ ] her movie was really good
was it emma was it the emma stone one
yeah i liked it i thought it was great
it got me into fashion there's a
spin-off of just her live action it's
like it's her it's her prequel it's like
how she changes
and it's kind of fire you know it is
kind of fire i'm also i kind of like it
so then you go you know what gorilla i
understand why you want to kill
dalmatians and i'm with you yeah is
there really a way you can empathize
with her yeah yeah oh yeah dude only one
yes i only watched the beginning [ __ ]
start out as anne frank and then grows
up do you want spoilers are you gonna
watch that or do you want some spoilers
as a person well i just i just have
hardcore opinions about things i don't
know got it it's most of america in the
beginning you might have seen this but
basically it's actually uh uh somebody
else who like makes these two older
dominations kind of like attack her was
it her mom yeah and push her mom over
there yeah so it's not really the dog's
fault it's like the dog's master that
commanded them so then it creates this
kind of like association to do the thing
with like it's it's really the blame is
on owners right
you guys have to watch it but he gave
you a good rundown yeah but that's
that's not spoiling the story but that
sets it up because obviously it goes
from her
as a backstory she's not evil and those
are actually my favorite stories about
bad people that they're not just born
evil and there's just some sort of
[ __ ] anticipation i want to watch it
because i i think it connects to it man
5.
mike tyson back part of the extended
man universe yeah and she actually [ __ ]
up a man
yo the budget for the most recent it man
have you guys seen all the it man yeah i
love them i feel like the most recent
ones it looked like the budget started
just doing this so bad was like
recession it man look like they were
rushing yeah i think the first one was
the best one
i disagree first one was the most like
emotional this one
with the [ __ ] dude's head right here
dude and that dude that came from
northern china he was like bad ass yeah
and then two three four five he becomes
a little [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah his
character argues he gets tamed he gets
tamed yeah he was so badass in that one
yeah i liked him as a feral [ __ ]
warrior i love the scene where mike
tyson is breaking all the windows
yeah also it's crazy to see like donnie
ends like
he just it looks like the botox works
but then it also looks like he's really
old and it's like his face is starting
to fall it's kind of crazy
didn't he get sick
or was that jet lag
that's really crazy too he got sick in
real life jelly's like look like super
old like recent pictures and stuff
because he like had some disease or like
some genetic conditioning yeah yeah so
because he because you remember what
like what jetley looked like and when he
was like starting all in all his movies
and then like recent pictures he's like
baldy looking he's got like these round
glasses it's like this guy justin baez
exactly like him was jelly in shanxi no
he wasn't
in something semi recently
romeo almost died three
[Laughter]
i miss aliyah it's [ __ ] up that they
ain't kissed though i was like i thought
it was kissed the whole time i was like
you guys have to kill there was so much
tension yeah there's so much sexual
tension she's probably like nah
i i think i think she would have been
down actually i think that i think there
was a huge gap but that that never
stopped that's not really an issue right
i mean didn't stop our kelly is what i'm
thinking but you know like that's a good
reference
what a great way to equip this wonderful
i hope we are all compared to our kelly
one kill one just pissing on kids
about to save
he pissed off wait i think they got
married uh aaliyah and kelly yeah they
did yeah yeah
so she's used to age gap she she drank a
lot of pee too so oh that's the
connection yeah she's got some age gaps
that's why yeah she's accustomed to it
so she's like this is cool i'm into it
this is fine with me she's really yeah
that really went there
cool but that is that is so because
you're asking the right questions yeah
no i i i totally forgot actually was
married on kellyanne i just figured she
was like 15 years she was underage it
was wasn't it like an illegal like thing
no i think it's like you can legally man
i think her parents signed off on that
and she during that period she made the
song aj nothing but a number
and it was for our character too oh my
god meanwhile this 2021 article that
came out uh from the new york times like
r kelly sexually abused aaliyah when she
was 13 or 14 a witness says
witness was a former backup dancer uh
let's
forget the cats you just made it to real
what the [ __ ] what do you mean
what the [ __ ] stop
dude
new york times i wasn't gonna search cat
fur
let's back up to this [ __ ] coat
you're wearing and it's got cat [ __ ]
also why were these cats still hungry if
they ate her
i'm looking at our kellyanne area right
now it's really hard to go back guys
isn't that the thing when you're when
you die the cats eat your face first
because the easiest to like it's really
maybe like because you're wearing
clothes yeah
sometimes you die with nothing but a
helmet on you know
they'll still go for your face are you
going to die with a motorcycle you're
like catching my [ __ ] face they're
not going to get my brain
i mean if uh it was the old superman it
was old superman movie with kevin spacey
it's that one it's one of those movies
where he's lex luthor where he's lex
luther something like that where there
was like two cats
and then in a house and then one of them
[ __ ] eats the other one what one cat
eats the other cat yeah
never mind anyways that happens because
same the same thing it's like once once
uh the owner dies or something like that
and the cats are left in the house
eventually there's some sort of
cannibalism they regress to like yeah
yeah they gotta eat cat's gotta be
hungry you know everybody's gotta i mean
humans do it too right yeah yeah yeah so
this isn't a story 20 cats eat their
dead owner when they're stuck but also
have less cats and that's the end of the
video oh yeah have less cats would 20
would 20 passengers in a plane crash eat
the one dead pilot sure yeah yeah you do
eat them you have to that's what anthony
says all i'm saying is we would all
start with bart ask first you think i
think that would be why ask first
because let's just stand up stand up nah
stand up we're gonna objectify i'm a
person
[Music]
you